[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 23 janvier
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de tv
60,18 c'est le tour d'horizon de
l'actualité locale en 26 minutes tout de
suite les titres
est ce le signe de tensions à la
verrière très élus de la majorité ont
créé récemment leur propre groupe au
sein du conseil municipal parmi eux
notamment l'ancien édile alain ajaj ils
se disent en désaccord sur certains
sujets avec la mère nelly du tube
explications à suivre s'est lancé depuis
hier les jeunes ont jusqu'au 14 mars
pour formuler leurs voeux sur parcours
sup la plateforme d'admission post bac
et des choix qui peuvent s'avérer
difficile dans son dernier ouvrage la
viroflay zianveni azzaro donne des clés
pour s'en sortir elle est notre invité
est dans cette édition reportage au sein
de la clinique des franciscaines à
versailles l'établissement est un pôle
d'excellence dans la chirurgie
vertébrale
les techniques utilisées permettent au
patient une récupération plus rapide et
nous avons pu suivre une opération
et puis nous présenterons également dans
cette édition la prochaine nuit des
métiers et de l'orientation de montigny
le bretonneux nouvelle journée marquée
par les chutes de neige dans le
département des yvelines des
précipitations qui sont tombées par
intermittence cet après midi jusqu'à 5
cm et c'était compliqué ce matin sur les
routes avec une circulation ralentie et
quelques accidents
côté transports lé réseau stibus effet
bus ont été grandement perturbée ce
mercredi des problèmes également sur la
ligne l du transilien la nationale 118
reste ce soir interdite aux poids lourds
saint quentin en yvelines a prévu de
ressortir ces engins de salage cette
nuit à partir de 3h30 météo france qui a
levé l'alerté orange cet après midi à 16
heures nous sommes désormais en
vigilance jaune à la neige mais
attention après après cette neige des
gelées sont attendues pour la nuit
prochaine avec des températures jusqu'à
-4 degrés localement et des conditions
très propice à la création de verglas
essayer de différer vos déplacements
dans la mesure du possible et si vous
devez absolument utiliser votre véhicule
opté pour la plus grande prudence
politique locale une division au sein de
la du conseil municipal de la verrière
depuis décembre un groupe appelé
rassemblement des élus pour la verrière
c est créé au sein de la majorité
une façon d'afficher les désaccords sur
certains un projet de la mère nelly
duthu les précisions de nicolas d'ombré
des voeux 2010 9 à la verrière avec des
élus absents peut être le signe d'une
certaine tension très élus ont créé au
sein de la majorité le groupe
rassemblement des élus pour la verrière
le 12 décembre dernier
parmi ces élus l'ancien maire alain
ayache contraint de démissionner en 2016
pour raisons de santé et de céder son
siège à nelly du tube 6 créé séquoia sur
certains sujets on estime qu on n'est
pas entendus il ya un manque de
concertation ou autre chose
voyez donc nous notre démarche allait
pas comment dirais-je qu'on n'est pas
dans une confrontation
nous on est à constructif qu'on sera
constructive jusqu'au bout et toujours
force de proposition ce qui est sûr
c'est que soit l'âge on avait passé
quoique et 7 ces petites tensions qui
aujourd'hui existait voilà j'avais un
risque était fort rassemblés à l'origine
le conseil municipal du 12 décembre
dernier avec une délibération concernant
la nouvelle crèche du quartier orly-parc
des divergences au sein de la majorité
concernant son emplacement qui entraîne
la création de ce groupe
sincèrement moi j'en suis donné un jeu
je prends acte de la création de ce
groupe
on va se parler et puis l'idée l'idée
quand même et et de retourner aux
élections unis parce que
ce serait quand même dommage qu'avec
tout ce qui est c'est fait depuis trente
ans sur cette ville notre opposant
politique
se servent de tout ça
dans un panier quoi on espère surtout du
calme que les dossier puisse avancer que
les esprits retrouve la sérénité et la
concorde pour cette nouvelle année
on prépare bien évidemment l'avenir
on a des projets on a une équipe motivée
on a plein dans vie plein d'
enthousiasme
al'approche de l'élection municipale de
2020 et league où tu souhaite avoir des
discussions sans exclure de se
représenter politique locale toujours on
accueille sur ce plateau marylène
iapichino bonsoir lundi soir avait lieu
les voeux de montigny le bretonneux le
maire jean-luc ourgaud a dressé un bilan
de l'année 2018 oui puisque un bilan de
2018 c'est même un bilan de son mandat
que le maire de montigny le bretonneux
adressé à ferme du manet il affirme que
ses objectifs sont atteints à 90% et
pour 2019
quatre gros chantiers seront attaquées
ce qui attend les habitants de montigny
c'est la poursuite de notre programme je
pense qu'on a la chance d'avoir comme je
les dis une ville qui financièrement est
très bien gérée donc je la plus belle
réalisation va être bien sûr le forum
des arts charles aznavour qui va sortir
de terre là on commence les travaux
bonne mars
et puis après le club le village ensuite
le centre de la petite enfance à la
place de l'école samain et la maison de
santé pluridisciplinaire ça c'est
vraiment je veux dire ces quatre groupes
se sont quatre beaux projets
ont contribué à gérer achever le
programme sur lequel on s'était engagé
et jean-luc urgo est également revenu
sur la fibre une histoire de longue date
à montigny dont il espère enfin un
dénouement sfr s'étant engagé il ya
quelques jours à mettre là justement en
place dans la ville
et concernant le grand débat national
qui suit en ce moment marianne c'est
jusqu'au 15 mars commence là cela
va-t-il se mettre en place
à montigny alors là dessus le maire a
été très clair il remplira son rôle de
mère en facilitant l'organisation de ce
grand débat mais il n'en sera pas
l'animateur puisque selon lui les sujets
soulevés sont nationaux merci marc idem
pour ce point d'information va regarder
tout de suite votre reportage au sein de
la clinique francisque end à versailles
un autre sujet celui de la chirurgie
vertébrale l'établissement yves binois
et pôle d'excellence dans ce domaine des
technologies de pointe que vous avez pu
observer lors d'une opération
la préparation est plus longue pour un
rétablissement plus rapide dans cette
clinique de versailles à la pointe de la
technologie sur la chirurgie vertébrale
la chirurgie et mini invasive
le but est d'être le moins agressif
possible de faire saigner le moins
possible d'ouvrir le moins possible aux
prendre le moins de risques possibles
pour cela le bloc opératoire un
équipement spécial encore peu répandu de
par son coût on a des moyens dit
je ris avec des systèmes de guidage et
systèmes de reconstruction
tridimensionnel qui vont aider le
chirurgien à voir aussi bien que s'il
avait ouvert complètement a guidé son
geste et à rendre le geste encore une
fois moins lourd pour le patient en fait
cette machine appelée aux armes ce
qu'elle une première fois le patient
pour prendre toutes les mesures
nécessaires aux chirurgiens fait les
images 3d une fois qu'elles vont être
acquise elles vont être injectés dans la
navigation pour virtualiser en 3d comme
vraiment ces principes grossier on va
dire du gps qui repère une voiture sur
la route va nous va repérer des
instruments chirurgicaux sur la colonne
en fait ces instruments il peut
désormais les retrouver sur son écran
qui va l'aider à opérer de façon très
précise pour ce patient atteint de
scoliose le docteur le peintre va
retirer trois disques de la colonne
vertébrale et les remplacer par des
implants après plusieurs mesures de
précisions le chirurgien peut introduire
une broche puis son système d'écartement
pour aller chercher le disque a retiré
le tout sous couvert d'un euro
monitoring pour s'assurer que
l'opération n'est pas agressif pour les
racines nerveuses tout doucement
une fois le disque totalement retiré le
chirurgien peut placer l'implant et
n'hésitent pas à s'y prendre à plusieurs
fois en contrôlant chaque geste par le
scanner oui on a des repères radiopaq
sur l'implant qu'on m'ait et en les
alignant des structures anatomiques bien
précises pour que le plan soit
positionné comme on le désire
là il est positionné comme on le désire
voilà plus que deux disques a remplacé
pour que le patient ressortent sans ses
douleurs de dos au total l'opération
dure environ 1h30 il est installé face à
la gare de poissy depuis mai dernier le
puits de carbone a eu un réel impact sur
la qualité de l'air premier bilan
positif dressé par suez après sept mois
d'expérimentation cette installation qui
capte les polluants grâce à la
photosynthèse aurait absorbé selon la
direction autant de co2 que 50 arbres ce
test est le troisième de cette nature en
france après l'installation de puits à
paris et à colombes dans les
hauts-de-seine
depuis hier la plateforme parcours sup
est ouverte les lycéens de terminale ont
jusqu'au 14 mars pour saisir leurs voeux
mais deux invités autour de la table
sont là pour vous aider à choisir la
bonne orientation bonsoir eric stoner en
soins vous êtes le directeur du service
jeunesse vie des quartiers à montigny le
bretonneux la ville qui organise mardi
prochain sa nuit des métiers et de
l'orientation mercredi prochain par dont
on sera le 29 29 janvier vous vous
restez avec nous on va en parler dans un
instant et jenny azzaro également avec
nos gonds soir bonsoir
alors vous donner des cours
d'orientation vous avez travaillé
notamment dans le domaine des ressources
humaines vous êtes originaire de
viroflay
et vous avez publié récemment ce livre
cap orientation vous facilitez parcours
sup c'est aux éditions les passagères
vous y donne est toute une méthodologie
pour choisir son orientation
une orientation qui rime avec
complications avec le nom de formation
de métier aussi qui évolue avec le temps
ça peut s'assimiler avec un casse tête
c'est si difficile de s'orienter
c'est difficile mais surtout ça demande
du temps ça demande du temps pour
réfléchir à la fois à qui on est
qu'est ce qui vous fait avancer et quels
sont les métiers qui peuvent répondre à
vos attentes et qui ont des débouchés
évidemment c'est pour cette raison que
vous avez écrit le livre donner des clés
à ces jeunes et aux parents aussi
exactement en fait j'interviens beaucoup
en deuxième année de fac donc les gens
en général les jeunes sont orientés mais
quand je vois les difficultés qu'ils ont
à se projeter dans un métier je me dis
il faudrait commencer plus tôt à
travailler sur l'orientation pour au
moins avoir une idée de là où on se
dirige est ce que ce livre s'adresse aux
jeunes et à leurs parents aux deux aussi
peut-être alors je pense que quand on a
une difficulté d'orientation etc on est
jeune on a un peu de mal à se mettre en
face du problème donc les parents sont
souvent là pour aider et d'ailleurs les
jeunes il ya eu des enquêtes qui ont été
faites disent qu'ils comptent beaucoup
sur leurs parents pour cette étape donc
finalement c'est c'est un couple gagnant
gagnant les jeunes les parents pour
l'orientation non pas reconstruit pas
ouvert jusqu'au 14 mars les jeunes
pourront saisir leurs voeux ensuite une
deuxième phase phase pardon jusqu'au 3
avril pour confirmer ses voeux et
finaliser les dossiers avant le début
des réponses à ce sera à partir du 15
mai qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire johnny
hazzard ou est-ce qu'il faut se
précipiter bien réfléchir avant de
saisir ses voeux où il ne faut pas
attendre trop longtemps
enfin le monde c'est super c'est un
outil donc la démarche d'orientation
dans les lycées à la commencé bien plus
tôt dès novembre il y a eu des journées
d'orientation dans les lycées avec les
professeurs parfois avec des invités qui
ont donné des métiers donc en fait
logiquement on devrait être en bout de
réflexion au bout de ce tueur ce cela
maintenant certains jeunes et certains
parents peuvent prendre du retard
donc maintenant il faut quand même
mettre les bouchées doubles parce qu'il
ya à peu près cette semaine pour faire
pour finaliser ses choix et cette
semaine ça passe vite
du coup si on est totalement dans le
flou aujourd'hui que faut-il faire je
dirais que on peut faire comme comme
beaucoup de gens ont fait c'est-à-dire
procéder par élimination
mais en réalité la première chose c'est
de commencer à se demander qui on est
parce que en matière d'orientation en
fait on est à une époque on n'exerce pas
qu'un seul métier et il n'y a pas qu'une
seule manière d'aboutir à un métier donc
ça c'est très important à prendre en
compte dans l'autre ouvrage faire
connaissance avec soin mais il faut se
connaître
il faut se connaître sa motivation
ses goûts ses aspirations ses
difficultés aussi et puis après le
marché du travail est forcément des
compétences fondamentales à hacker pour
appréhender ce marché du travail
exactement en fait quand on regarde une
fois qu'on connaît ses compétences la
france a mis en place des outils assez
performant pour faire le lien entre les
compétences et les formations des outils
ou des lieux comme le ses idées j comme
les cio comme la cité de la villette
donc on peut trouver à partir de ses
compétences en matière à détecter des
métiers qui peuvent convenir
qu'est ce qu'on y trouve dans ce livre
aussi des outils forcément dans
l'habitation en fait ce qu'on trouve
c'est une méthode une méthode d'abord
savoir qui on est en quelque sorte
ensuite posez des scénarios
d'orientation et ensuite les confronter
au réel
parce qu'en fait quand on a un peu une
visibilité son métier qu'on veut faire
souvent c'est une représentation qu'on a
du métier et il est très important de la
de faire des enquêtes métier ou de
rencontrer des gens qui en particulier
pour voir si on s'est pas fait des
stéréotypes le stéréotype je veux être
trader où je veux être chirurgien
voilà où avocat fiscaliste non il faut
aller voir les gens qu'il exerce ses
métiers et les questionner et parfois en
deux entretiens bien fait le jeune que
vraiment acquérir une connaissance du
métier et ça c'est fondamental
question est-ce qu'il faut avoir peur de
l'échec on peut se tromper parfois dans
son orientation il faut avoir peur de
cet échec
l'orientation c'est souvent une
succession de ou d'échec ou de
bifurcation
le tout c'est de connaître sa colonne
vertébrale n'oublions pas que les
écoliers d'aujourd'hui
il y en a 60 5% qui vont occuper des
métiers que personne ne connaît donc sa
part et finalement le fil rouge c'est se
connaître soi même
merci denis azzaro auteurs de ce livre
cap orientation vous facilitez parcours
succès disponible aux éditions les
passagères au prix de 18 euros
autre solution pour y voir plus clair la
nuit des métiers de l'orientation ça se
passe mercredi
29 janvier au pôle jeunesse de montigny
le bretonneux 18h et 21h pour les
horaires et c'est en accès libre et rick
steiner je rappelle que vous êtes le
directeur du service jeunesse vie des
quartiers pour la ville et c'est un
événement qui ne s'adresse pas qu'aux au
lycée ans et plus globale on a souhaité
dès le départ en 2011 que ça soit un
événement s'adresse collégiens lycéens
mais aussi étudiants parce que quel que
soit le public dans ce dans ce parcours
entre guillemets qui va des études
jusqu'à l'intégration dans le milieu
professionnel
les questions se posent à toutes les
étapes on sait aujourd'hui qu'une grande
partie des étudiants c'est sûr étude la
première année entre 40 et 50% les
lycéens je veux dire c'est aussi très
compliqué de se projeter
il ya les métiers qu'on projette on
parle de stéréotypes les quelques
instants mais c'est un peu ça et des
réalités sont parfois différentes et le
collégien également parce que ce
parcours illégal malgré tout déterminant
ça ne va pas aller en s'arrangeant
l'horizon 2021 qui va changer entre
guillemets l'entrée en seconde et tout
le parcours secondes jusqu'à la
terminale va être questionné aussi bien
les jeunes que leurs parents et de 7,8
débat du thriller sera d'ailleurs qu'on
sur la réforme du bac avec aurélie rose
donc au travers de cet événement on
essaye entre guillemets de répondre de
manière la plus exhaustive possible mais
ne soyons pas à rebondir
c'est assez compliqué aux jeunes à leurs
parents qui se posent une multitude de
questions et dans une démarche très
partenariale puisque depuis maintenant
neuf ans on a un certain nombre de
partenaires autour de la table qui sont
aussi des spécialistes soit de
l'information jeunesse soit des métiers
donc ça va tester des métiers trappes
yvelines information jeunesse on aura
cette année le service orientation
insertion lu vs qu on aura des jeunes
aussi pour témoigner car il ya beaucoup
de coups d'acteurs beaucoup de
partenaires pour organiser pourquoi
organiser ce rendez vous le disiez c'est
de donner les clés on vous le disait
jenny azzaro l'orientation c'est quelque
chose de très difficile
c'est un processus long c'est un
processus long mais c'est aussi même un
processus où on dit à un moment donné il
est possible de prendre une pause ou
positive
je veux dire si vous n'êtes pas au clair
aujourd'hui sur le projet professionnel
on peut aussi faire un service civique
on peut
partir à l'europe extérieur multitude de
dispositifs qu'ils disent et ça peut
aussi être utile pour faire mûrir entre
guillemets à la fois qui on est et du
coup un projet professionnel derrière et
sur l'horaire 18h 21h c'est pour
faciliter l'accès à tout le monde à dire
les jeunes après leur journée de
d'écoles de collèges de lycées et les
parents après leur journée de travail
voilà et puis on essaie de faire ça dans
un dans un contexte un peu convivial
eurent même un grand jeu à 10 km autour
de l'orientation
c'est un bon horaire en fait que ce soit
les étudiants lycéens collégiens les
parents sont disponibles ce terrain
c'est plutôt un bon horaire on a lancé
ça en 2011 chaque année ça marche très
bien
après ils ont peuvent revenir tout au
long de l'année parce que c'est un
service quasiment permanent mais c'est
un moment qui permet de lancer quelque
chose où tout le monde peut de
disponible pour parler des escaliers
mais on pourra enquêter sur les métiers
sur l'orientation c'est à dire qu'on
peut s'amuser sur avec l'orientation
tout à fait tout à fait partie des
choses ou n'a le droit ou en amoureux de
vous aussi autour de ça alors vous
évoquez un petit peu le contenu ça sera
divisé en plusieurs pôles se 7 me à des
métiers l'orientation c'est ça on aura
un pôle autour de l'apprentissage
on aura un pool bien sûr autour de
parcours sur un pool rescue sur
orientation insertion valeur de la
participation de jeunes qui sont déjà
dans les études qui peuvent témoigner
sont passés par là c'est un certain
d'avoir leurs témoignages louis puisque
lorsque les jeunes parlent aux jeunes
généralement ça
une voix qui porte un petit peu
différemment et je trouve que ça à 100
c'est quelque chose qu'on se connaît
depuis longtemps on y est arrivé cette
année parce que effectivement il ya des
portes ouvertes dans les lycées dans les
universités on rencontre souvent les
enseignants etc etc ce terrain ça n'a
pas la même portée lorsque ce sont des
jeunes qui explique comment s'est passée
cette intégration dans leur parcours
avec d'autres jeux j'ai noté un pôle
également individuels pour faire
connaissance avec soi même on en revient
à ce que ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
et gagner azzaro bien identifier ces ses
volontés ce que l'on veut faire plus
tard
oui et bien identifiée c'est pareil
jeunes il faut pas non plus dramatiser
la chose
on rentre dans une époque on ne fera
plus un métier mais probablement
plusieurs métiers donc je vais dire
voilà ce qui est intéressant de cette
savoir qui on est quelles sont les
attitudes qu'on a les appétences qu'on a
et ensuite de voir avec ce package
comment on peut rebondir vers quoi et on
peut très bien démarré dans une filière
avec un messi en tête qui déboucheront
fait sur d'autres métiers ce qu'il faut
aller chercher c'est ça c'est ses
appétences et aptitudes ses envies il
faut pas dramatiser la chose les nuits
des métiers et de l'orientation pardon
je vais y arriver qui est en accès libre
et gratuit c'est important de le
préciser merci eric castetner d'avoir
été avec nous je rappelle que cette nuit
est programmée le 29 janvier c'est au
pôle jeunesse des de montigny le
bretonneux c'est au parvis des sources
rendez-vous de 18h à 21h et je le disais
tout à l'heure l'éducation qui sera
d'ailleurs en question dans le 7-8 débat
aurait l'iran et ses invités parleront
de la réforme du baccalauréat et le 7-8
débat c'est à retrouver juste après ce
journal les yvelines qui confirme être
une terre propice au cinéma plusieurs
comédiens font partie de la liste des
nommés pour les césars 2010 9 dévoilé ce
matin parmi les potentiels meilleure
actrice mélanie thierry qui a grandi à
sartrouville elle concourt pour son rôle
dans la douleur un film d'emmanuel
finkiel adapté de l'oeuvre de marguerite
duras et dans la catégorie du meilleur
acteur dans un second rôle de versailles
à denis podalydès pour plaire aimé et
courir vite de christophe honoré et 10
nominations pour le grand bain de xavier
legrand et gilles lellouche avec aux
castings les yvelinois guillaume canet
et alban ivanov
enfin la présence également à noter dans
les meilleurs décors et meilleurs
costumes et d'un peuple et son roi
notamment une tournée et a notamment au
château de versailles
44e cérémonie des césar le 22 février
prochain
mercredi jour de sortie d'ailleurs au
cinéma omar sy est à la fiche de yao un
film qu'il a lui-même coproduit réalisé
par philippe philippe godeau le scénario
un acteur célèbre nez en france qui
vient pour la première fois sur la terre
de ses parents le sénégal pour présenter
un livre il va nouer des liens sur place
avec un petit garçon yao qui a fui son
village et parcouru plusieurs centaines
de kilomètres pour rencontrer la star
l'histoire
elle forcément celle de l'acteur de
trappes même si omar sy elle n'a
lui-même jamais coupé les ponts avec ses
origines
direction saint cyr l'école à présent
pour notre petit tour hebdomadaire des
cinémas du coin présentation de la
programmation aux yeux d'elsa c'est au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude le
film que nous vous conseillons au cinéma
cette semaine au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
en particulier c'est le film edmond
alors c'est un film de alexis michalik
qui est sorti récemment et que certains
d'entre vous ont peut-être hésité à
aller voir se disant ah je n'ai pas vu
la pièce de théâtre
j'aurais préféré voir la pièce avant etc
moi je vous dis que il faut voir les
deux toute façon et puis que vous allez
voir quelque chose de complètement
différent alors évidemment le récit de
la pièce de théâtre et le récit du film
sont les mêmes
petit retour en arrière la pièce de
théâtre 2010 cette aide mon grand grand
succès dans le théâtre privé 5 molière
enfin un véritable succès à paris et en
tournée en est sorti en adaptation à ce
récit théâtral le film est réalisé par
l'auteur de la pièce et il s'amuse
vraiment dans ce film a travaillé du
cinéma évidemment le thé au théâtre on
est face à des acteurs sur une scène et
comme vous le savez le film nous parle
de la réalisation de la conception du de
la pièce cyrano de bergerac par edmond
rostand et bien là dans le film il va
nous faire faire ce qu'il peut pas faire
au théâtre c'est à dire qu'il va nous
faire entrer dans la pièce montée sur
scène être avec les acteurs être avec
les comédiens tournée avec eux je vous
préviens gérard myrmidon car la fin de
l'envoi je louche je touche
nous allons modestement crayères
ensemble un château je vous conseille
véritablement vivement c'est une très
très belle histoire d'amour
c'est une très belle histoire d'amitié
c'est une très belle histoire de
création et c'est une très belle
réflexion du cinéma sur le théâtre
j'espère vraiment pouvoir nombreux ici
au cinéma les yeux d'elsa cette semaine
la semaine prochaine et partout ailleurs
en france c'est un film qui vont
vraiment le détour
et puis peut-être que votre enfant
préfère le champ au cinéma la maîtrise
du cmbv fait pour lui ce week-end le
centre de musique baroque de versailles
organise une journée portes ouvertes
pour découvrir le quotidien de ces
jeunes du à ce1 à la troisième une
première étape avant un recrutement
peut-être à la rentrée prochaine mélanie
poker
[Applaudissements]
lena clélia guillaume timothée son page
au centre de musique baroque de
versailles les pages ce sont les enfants
à partir de la sixième qui vont assurer
production et confrères ils ont tous les
4 14 ans et son élève de 3e
moi personnellement j'étais assez petit
j'étais en cp avec cet effet ciel de sa
marge et mais je savais juste que
j'aimais chanter que donc ça me plaisait
de chanter quoi c'était mon frère qui
était d'abord au cmv et mes parents ont
décidé de m'inscrire aussi ce jour là
ils répètent sous la direction d'olivier
cheney belling le directeur musical et
pédagogique de la maîtrise le 21 février
et chanteront philippe hersant à radio
france
c'est vraiment de déjà de fonder
vraiment un groupe de fonder un groupe
et donc que chacun se sente responsable
au sein du groupe donc à différents
niveaux de responsabilité évidemment
j'ai pas avoir les mêmes exigences avec
des jeunes 6e qu'avec des grands
troisième avec ce
ce sentiment qu'on développe chez eux ça
ça mène à plus de plaisir ça mène à
moins compter le temps qu'on passe en
répétition voilà ils ont ils sont
toujours en soif d'être là de montrer
qu'ils savent faire
la maîtrise et en cham les classes à
horaires aménagés
le matin ils sont à l'école et au
collège l'après-midi cours de chant et
répétitions cmbv on va au collège et non
de 8 heures à 13 heures ou 14 heures et
puis on arrive au sel mais vais juste
après on commence la répétition
après généralement on a une pause d'une
demi heure et jusqu'à 17h 17h30 en
continu de la répétition
c'est peut-être 3 3 4 heures par jour
c'est comme des cours normaux donc s'il
fait un peu une sorte de petite troupe
vocale qui va se retrouver donc ici
quatre après midi par semaine les lundi
mardi jeudi et vendredi qui va leur
donner l'occasion de donner de très beau
concert à la chapelle royale du château
de versailles
mais aussi des tournées en france et à
l'étranger
les rendez vous à la chapelle royale ce
sont les jeudis musicaux 24 sont
organisées sur la saison 2018-2019 de
novembre à juin une dernière répétition
avant de se produire devant une salle
pleine
un moment de stress malgré l'habitude
les preuves sont là pour ça et entre nos
g on a un petit geste qui est qui ne
souhaite bonne chance et moi j'étais
stressée pour cinq ans
certaines et après petit à petit on
prend goût et on s'habitue on va voir un
certain nombre de publie un certain
nombre de personnes en face de nous un
loisir passion pour certains une volonté
d'en faire son métier plus tard pour
d'autres
près de 60 enfants sont chaque année en
classe à horaires aménagés sur
versailles le recrutement débute au
niveau du ce1
une info sports avant de vous a laissé
qui nous est parvenu cet après-midi le
jumping international de versailles est
annulé il était prévu du 26 au 28 avril
dans un communiqué publié sur facebook
les organisateurs évoquent une
conjoncture incompatible avec
l'organisation d'un tel événement ce
jumping lancé pour la première fois en
2017 avait déjà rencontré des obstacles
avec une annulation en 2018
c'est la fin du set 8 journal belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]